beyond the beauty of the fall in
Pennsylvania
beyond the calm and the quiet of a place
called Harmony is this a nation on the
brink
is the Great American experiment
faltering are these United States slowly
or maybe quite quickly ripping
themselves apart
they call Pennsylvania the Keystone
State the place where the American
Constitution was signed it keeps drawing
me back
scene I watched as it shook the nation
swinging to Trump delivering him the
White House anybody that's going for
Trump
[Applause]
four years later it edged back Biden's
birth state was blue again
but that's when it all started
wow what a beautiful day thank you from
the unlikely setting of a car park in a
Philadelphia landscaping business Donald
Trump's lawyer Rudy Giuliani but they
were uniformly deprived of their right
to inspect any single part of the
mail-in ballot
he was setting the stage for a con which
would in time consume the country
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
over and over
two years on the midterm elections will
set the nation's course
knock knock but to what extent are they
framed by evidence-free claims of
election fraud Cindy yes hi local
Republican campaigner Cindy Hildebrand
has invited me to meet a group of
friends at their local party HQ of
course policies dominate the chat
they're out to lunch with the border
with drugs with crime with inflation
their values on abortion drugs guns the
economy are conservative I don't even
talk to Democrats trying to convince
them to change their vote because it's
like talking to a wall but I wanted to
know about the more fundamental question
so how many of you here believe
that Donald Trump
should have won or did win the last
election absolutely did win
you all think the election was stolen by
Biden I think there is a overwhelming
uh evidence
that the 2020 election was at least
tampered with if not outright stolen and
that has caused a permanent divide
that's actually helped push the sides
apart now I'm telling you for for sure
that we know that there were enough
irregularities to change some results
across counties and let's not forget
that our state in Pennsylvania has been
controlled by a governor who's a
Democrat an attorney general who's a
Democrat and Pennsylvania Supreme Court
Justices who've been placed by democrats
for the last decade so you think they're
corrupts in their lying well certainly
here's the problem they believe they're
failing to get their way on legitimate
conservative policies not because a
majority might disagree with them but
because they think a minority stole the
election from them and they're not alone
this isn't a fringe view in a Republican
party still dominated by Donald Trump
polls suggest 70 percent believe he won
they dismiss recounts audits court cases
across the land even Trump's own
attorney general with this extreme made
it clear I did not agree with the idea
of saying the election was stolen and
putting out this stuff which I told the
president he became the enemy rather
than the defender of Truth
s of the younger generation which matter
then these two activists both 20 hardly
give hope Zack and Corey call themselves
the Patriots and they're standing for
office in their local Republican youth
group
it should be encouraging that they're so
engaged but listen to their predictions
America's at stake if we if if we lose
it our country's going to hell I think I
think it's a Civil War I I truly do
really yes I I think that's I think
that's the only thing that's gonna
that's gonna bring America back together
after this election if we lose
that's an extraordinary frightening
prediction it is I mean but look look
back to
um you know back in back in the old days
I mean that seemed to fix it the first
time
so
it's not what you want it's not what I
want at all but I mean we're out of
options it's
we're losing I mean we're going to lose
the entire country if something's not
done about it
the road on the other side of the divide
the Democrats are out in force for their
local candidate for the senate in
Washington here they believe the doubt
sown into the fabric of American society
threatens everything there's lots of
talk about the the threat to Democracy
in America do you think that's
overstated or do you think genuinely
there is there is a threat I think it
might be understated
um I think there's a genuine threat to
democracy in this country and it really
scares the hell out of me
why
don't I don't want to end up like what
we've seen in Europe in the past you
know if if we don't learn from history
we're doomed to repeat it
and we need to uphold democracy to
to keep going
I'm very concerned more concerned than
you were just a couple of years ago
absolutely
it is so polarized and our last
president
did so much to to
tear this country apart we have got to
get it back together
reflecting on all the conversations here
it is kind of jolting there is so much
going on so many different issues a
growing division no doubt and absolutely
no trust between the two sides there's
anger for sure but I felt fear among
people too a real sense that they don't
know what comes next and they don't know
how they themselves would react to it
my final stop is to meet a man I last
saw two years ago
in those frenetic days after the 2020
election in Philadelphia Al Schmidt was
the Republican election commissioner
telling anyone who would listen that his
party didn't win there was no fraud
Trump lost
counting votes cast on or before
election day
by eligible voters is not cheating it's
democracy for that he received death
threats his family too Trump singled him
out in a tweet so what are his
Reflections now we've hardly made a dent
since 2020 in changing people's minds
and it's not like something has come out
since then that would add any evidence
to this paranoid fantasy of a storm
election
why do you think you haven't made a dent
I don't know and I don't know that it's
a question that I'm in a position to to
answer I think there's something deeper
going on like for example
is this Embrace in election denial
because you have a significant number of
people who really aren't
okay with democracy
they're really not okay with the fact
that the winner should be who the
majority of Voters selected
today's America is siled in Echo
Chambers so many consume wildly partisan
cable news they believe social media
they dismiss factual reporting
conspiracy theories spread faster than
truth
humility decency respect values that are
harder and harder to find Mark Stone Sky
News in Pennsylvania